thanks bro Hey this house is bitchin you
everybody shows up loading loading
loading loading and it says this house
is spigen hey everybody it's Charlie
this is gonna be my flash episode 22
video we had so many big comic book
Easter eggs they introduced a really big
flash comic book concept that I've been
waiting for them to address for a long
time now there's a new round of that
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video but this house is
bitchin let's do top 10 WTF and comic
book Easter eggs starting with number 10
welcome back evil Diggle this Deveaux
version of Diggle was hilarious because
it's David Ramsey the actor from arrow
pretending to be DeVoe pretending to be
Diggle I'm the dude playing a dude
pretending to be another dude we get
this great montage of him using all of
his metahuman abilities to run the
gauntlet at Argos to get to fallout but
the reason why they had him used the in
excelsis deo music was is because it's a
Christian him in the big line he went
out on was God said let there be light
as he was starting the enlightenment so
they were weaving a little bit of
Christian mythology there but it sort of
confirmed my suspicion that the
Enlightenment would actually begin in
the very end of this episode so the
finale will pick up in the moments after
this so like we've already hit the
Enlightenment [ __ ] is going down so
number 9 they bring back irises blogg
she's trying to use all the people of
the city that are reading it to
crowdsource Marla's location this is
just more of them seeding plot for
season 5 or what a coincidence that when
we go back to Barry and irises apartment
you see all of the boxes of her evidence
the paper says she's been poring over
trying to learn more about this this is
the stuff that she's going to be doing
during season 5 so they want to get you
prepared for that so that when they have
problems during season 5 they all used
their different abilities like some of
them are scientists iris is a reporter
she does research that's what she'll be
doing when it comes time for her to
contribute when they're trying to solve
a problem as a team so they also use
that later in the episode to when
they're trying to find Marlies they look
back into her past so iris does a whole
bunch of research about her time at
Oxford number 8 Caitlin is in therapy
I'm not a big fan of the therapist but I
feel like this is all just set up for
the payoff at the end of the episode
when she realizes what was really going
on with killer frost this whole time
most of
you probably caught the Ronnie shoutouts
I've seen my fiance died twice there's
actually three different versions of
Ronnie that we've seen die on the TV
show but I feel like if there's gonna be
a lot of group therapy sessions then it
should be like there were when Barry was
trying to get Caitlin to talk about it
when she was on the table no no I'm fine
I'm not a liability the team in Barry's
like no no no we need to work through
this those scenes work a little bit
better for me because it shows the team
working together which is what you want
to get to that's also probably one of
the reasons why they introduced that
Cecile power twist where she just starts
automatically reading people's minds and
then regurgitating their thoughts but
number seven welcome back Diggle for
real Barry whooshes them in they have a
big joke about him throwing up the funny
thing about this is that earlier on
arrow this season there was a flash
crossover without Grant Gustin it was
just like a CG real quick moment of
lightning whooshing Oliver and Diggle to
a piece of road where they're trying to
track down Kate and James Diggle did not
throw up when they dropped him off so a
lot of people were like is that a
continuity error how come Diggle isn't
throwing up but it was actually a pretty
brief Diggle crossover I think mostly
for that intro scene when it was being
the false version of Davos so Barry's
like I washed him back to Star City so
we're back to core team flash characters
but number six Cecile's new power or the
new wrinkle and her ability so they're
basically just saying the pregnancy
hormones are causing her ability to
become more broad-spectrum the way
Caitlin describes it is she's inhabiting
other people's minds but later in the
episode she actually thinks that she's
Joe and can't recognize the real Joe so
is this really weird spin like why would
they do something like this if it
weren't to reveal secrets that people
don't want to get out so I'm wondering
if they'll use this for a coffee girl
twist in the finale whereby she just
happens to be too close to Cecile in
proximity and Cecile just automatically
reads her mind and that's how we find
out what's going on with her but in the
trailer for the finale she's on the
birthing table so it kind of seems like
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
stretch her delivery period out over the
course of the finale so that by the
climax of the episode she is at the
climax of giving birth
number five Harrison wells is patient
zero for the Enlightenment they actually
clarify what's going on with him because
Marley's is like oh wow everybody is
gonna be like you in a little while so
that along with
conversation help bring her around a
little bit and if it wasn't clear the
speech that iris reminds her about that
she came back at Oxford we saw that
during a flashback when we saw the
origin of Devo and Marley's relationship
but number four this is a big one so if
you guys saw me tweeting during the
episode I said that they revealed a big
flash comic book concept it's actually
two separate comic book concepts most of
you probably picked up on this pretty
quickly
one Cisco reveals that Barry generates
speed force when he runs there's a small
twist on the idea from the new 52 that
Barry is the person who generated the
Speed Force himself like he's the prime
flash that created the Speed Force when
he was struck by lightning that all
other speedsters in all other realities
feed from this is just a slight twist on
that but the whole idea is is that Barry
on the TV show now can generate Speed
Force when he runs and share it so
sharing Speed Force is the other big
comic book concept we've seen people
steal Speed Force and dilute it using
special technology but now Barry knows
that he can share Speed Force without
using any special gear he could just
give it to other non speedsters if he
wants for a very brief period but
there's a ticking clock on that so I
think this is also a lead-up for season
5 concepts with the idea that Barry will
work with other people in other
speedsters and they will give and share
speed with each other
so when speedsters need a little extra
juice they can borrow speed from each
other number three team flash uses flash
time to get into Argus you can
definitely tell that they were banking a
lot of their special effects money for
these last two episodes so you have
Caitlin using a modified gauntlet that
they argue about I love that they argue
the name is it a frost gun is it a cold
gun is it an ice gun I think it's just a
proto of what she's gonna look like his
killer frost during season 5 in addition
to the new wrinkle that we've learned
the killer frost was always within her
but number two of course Caitlin vibes
back to her childhood and learns that
even as a young girl she would turn into
killer frost in times of extreme danger
she gets in some nasty bike wreck she
automatically hooks out so it sounds
like her experiencing extreme trauma is
what triggers it when she's not actively
conscious of what's going on but I think
we're getting to a place in season 5
where she's able to reconcile that with
inside her
she's able to call upon those powers
without having Cisco or Harrison wells
try to scare the death out of her in
order to bring her out so just expect
more Caitlyn in season five and more
killer frost as to whether or not she's
evil we don't know it just seems like
she'll have more control over the
transformations to killer frost but
obviously number one Deveaux hijacks
gideon and activates the Enlightenment
protocol using STAR Labs tech I like it
that STAR Labs is the location for all
these apocalyptic things that happen in
Central City like there are very few
times in the last couple of seasons when
something really terrible hasn't
happened at STAR Labs that is affected
the entire population there were some
funny shoutouts to the legion of Doom's
of Superfriends so it's always funny to
find out what actually exists in this
world because technically the Justice
League exists there is a Superman out
there somewhere but the way they
reference it is just so weird there is a
Cara in earth ones universe but because
Melyssa on earth 38 the actual Supergirl
that we see all the time is such a big
character they just don't want to do
earth one Supergirl
or at least due her yet they drop a
whole bunch of references to Barry's
gibberish from the beginning of the
season they say this house is bitchin
again and talked about the stars in the
sky so Joe has that conversation talking
to Cecile there's a star in the sky and
that star is you then Davo references
the stars then crazy Barry who had just
come out of the Speed Force at the
beginning of the season spoke can you
see the stars so it just sounds like
that's going to have something to do
with the enlightenment in this purple
sky that you see in the trailer for the
finale so while he was also quoting all
that Nietzsche in that final
conversation with Barry he also talked
about children so we have Cecile that's
getting ready to give birth to a baby
girl we have the hints about Barry and
iris having future children so there's
just a couple twists that they can take
that in but I'm expecting all of the
gibberish to be paid off by the finale
so probably the biggest one in my mind
that we still need confirmation on is is
we're going to need more diapers we have
to find out what other baby Barry is
referencing when he says more diapers in
addition to the diapers that they
already needed because of Cecile's baby
if she's not having twins it has to be
somebody else or some other twist on
that Ola coffee girl but like I said
what I'll do is my next video will be a
trail
video for the finale leave all your
questions in the comments below I'll try
to address that during the trailer video
and just let me know what was your
favorite part of this episode so we will
be talking about season five very soon
if you guys didn't see it they dropped a
whole bunch of news about Young Justice
season 3 the Titans TV show
cyborg coming to the Titans verse in a
Doom Patrol TV show click here to learn
about all that stuff then click here for
my solo Star Wars review I also recently
posted my Deadpool 2 non spoilery review
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight